hey mein name ist lokal kräftig spaß
beiseite mein name ist nicht luca wir
spielen aber tatsächlich heute eine
runde ko es gehe aber nicht nur kurz
gedauert ich habe gerade eben auf
twitter eine kleine umfrage gestartet
und habe euch gefragt was sie heute zu
sehen wollt weil ich einfach mal wissen
wollte wie so die meinung bei euch ist
zu verschiedenen games und habe als
antwort möglichkeit den rocket league
und micro van gegeben muss man also ein
kleines stimmungsbild zu bekommen de wit
vorhalte richtig habe und das ding war
ungefähr 45 prozent rocketlink oder 41
rocket liegen 60 prozent minecraft und
deswegen habe mir gedacht okay so dass
du musst du eine eine gruppe von leuten
enttäuschen aber falsch gedacht es muss
tatsächlich niemand enttäuscht werden
denn wir machen was heute so wir spielen
jetzt eine runde minecraft hier nämlich
ksg sehen zu dass es halbwegs was wird
wollte er sich ziemlich zumindest bis
auf die knochen blamieren obert ja und
danach hängen wir eine runde rocket
liegt dann wahrscheinlich ranked und ich
würde mal sagen alle die roccat liegt
noch nicht kennen
schaut auf jeden fall noch die ersten
paar sekunden von lockerbie kann denn
das spiel ist einfach richtig richtig
witzig das macht bock ich könnte mir
glauben also echt knapp
auch da habe ich noch nichts gehört im
spiel
aber ich kann euch sagen es macht
richtig bock ich mein ich habe davor
auch minecraft gespielt also kann ich
mir vorstelle dass es anderen minecraft
spielern ähnlich geht ist aber nächstes
spiel ich werde die reichen die regeln
dann gleich nochmal erklären wenn wir im
game drin sind jetzt erstmal hier gucken
dass wir überleben
aber es sollte nicht ganz klappen nein
ja
er hat blogger lokal schon sagen hatte
er hatte einfach zwei tnt direkt in die
fresse bekommen wenn der nicht von mir
stirbt da heißt es
wie heiß ich daran sigmar gabriel alles
klar
gut muss wir kurz überlegen ich dann
heißt ja manchmal vergisst man es
nämlich wenn man dumm ist seine bühne
so werden okay das war das gerade
bisschen frech von mir ich dachte hier
wird die axt an das war nicht der fall
so wie jetzt eigentlich schon direkt ins
deathmatch stadt wie viel haben wir noch
ein gegner okay dann gold zack ist schon
drin guten jetzt drauf hat auch eine
diashow es hat auch ein goldabbau
gegessen vielleicht aber wir können
leider nicht team ja die partikel
ich glaube ich einen gegessen hast du
gold apple gitter mein freund mein
kleiner freund ok sehr schön so damit
haben wir da und wir haben jetzt auch
minecraft für heute rum jetzt bringen
wir rüber zu rockig league auf 32 so da
sind wir leute bei rocket league spielen
gegen service bubblegum auto fußball und
es geht los
am anfang hat man diese anschluss
situation dir steht in seinem tor und
der ball liegt in der mitte da ist mein
gegner jetzt spielen das war hoch her
man kann mit den autos springen und
schnellfahren man kann so ziemlich alles
machen was irgendwie witzig ist von
actionlastig und man kann auch die
gegner kaputtmachen wenn man besonders
schnell von hinten rein fährt so und
sehr schön
ich bin noch relativ anfänger in diesem
spiel deswegen ich versucht euch noch
mal kurz zu erklären was so geht also
hauptsächlich halt springen und bust
einsammeln anklicken buß wenn man über
diese gelben plattform drüber fährt
dann legt sich der auf die boost anzeige
und wenn man dann einen knopf drückt auf
der xbox xbox controller
da ist es also der schießen knopfes fifa
dann
pustet der 1 dann fliegen die bälle
weiter man schickt wenn man den trifft
und man fährt schneller jetzt kann man
den ersten das erste tor machen erklärt
ihm fast noch aber okay 1 0 für uns
unser gegner sogar profis nur semi profi
sieht man ja wir spielen mit krankhafter
jetzt schon mit maxis account weil ich
mir selbst nicht das spiel gekauft habt
wie gesagt ich spiele es erst seit zwei
oder drei tagen
aber es braucht auf jeden fall ich will
noch nicht gut also ich bin noch relativ
schlecht aber wir können auch
theoretisch mal werde der bock drauf hat
nochmal ein turbo systems spiel
das geht auch man kann also nicht nur
eins gegen eins sondern auch zwei gegen
zwei ich glaube bis vier gegen vier oder
so ist das maximum htb verpasst er
machte nicht reingemacht nicht rein
im gegenteil sogar er legt noch ganz
zügig rüber übrigens diese dinge wo
sowas bisschen drüber schwebt mich
gefahren wenn die führen die boost
anzeige voll auf die anderen nur zehn
prozent
aber diese außen um zu wissen was
darüber schwebt sondern so eine art
hologramm die führen voll auf deswegen
sollte man eigentlich die einsame liegen
halt doch relativ weit außerhalb oder
schießen richtig weit weg er macht aber
nicht rein machst du nicht rein geht
übrigens auf das hier
hier seht ihr das
da habe ich so eine kuppe eine kappe
draufgezogen auf diesem stuhl mit das
spiel weiter eins zu eins oder zwillings
ein bisschen spannend so jetzt fahren
wir hier außen lang obwohl wir
eigentlich in sein sollte und den boost
zu holen weil am ende lohnt sich wenn
man viel schneller am ball ist und den
auch ewig wegschießen kann
und wir sind noch mal voll dabei und
juli 31 auf der reingeht
alter schwede richtig mies guck mal hier
drei kontakte sogar ich schieß ihn an er
bloggt auf mich und ich treffe noch mal
ein ansatz den banden treffer richtig
nice selber dieses match gewinnen der
sage ich wir müssen es schaffen dass so
ein tor ok ich schon seit ich
mitgenommen als ob schon wieder ich bin
so ein lager ich bin so ein junge wie
dumm die habe ich alter ich höre da
hätte ich nicht so gut klären können
jetzt mein eigenes tor gewesen wäre
haltern ein okay gut mit genau was da
geht auch so glaube ich oder sehr schön
da können auch nicht mehr machen 2321
aber schon
es gibt noch zu sagen also man kann so
ein doppel sprung machen der bewirkt
dass man den ball nochmal kickt mit dem
auto wenn er wenn er schon in der luft
ist also sieht dann so aus gesehen dass
man halt noch mal zum ball hingeht extra
dann fliegt er noch ein bisschen weiter
weg und man kann halt sonst einbußen
setzen 100 fuß punkte die kleinen
plattform für ein zehn punkte auf die
mit diesem diesem dragonball oben drüber
die füllen bisschen mehr auf nämlich 100
bisschen mehr auf 100 prozent also den
ganzen kreis da auch jetzt kommen
versuchen der luft zu nehmen
duisburg hat nicht stand einfach viel zu
schlechter die ausgangsposition
das stellungsspiel das war ein bisschen
suboptimal okay von seinem team aber
auch kurz hier außen die plattform mit
nero jetzt torschuss den kann aber
blocken glaube ich ja er verstand er gut
da
ja okay jetzt rüber gebracht
ich mache die richtige verrenkungen der
fans kämpft ja es untendrunter durch war
jetzt aufs tor als ob er nicht geht
kommt man rein junge warst schon
ja ja ja ja jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt
jetzt jetzt jetzt also vor seinem tor um
gammeln okay jetzt muss man gas geben er
macht ihn nicht will im ersten stock ein
glück gehabt glück gehabt gehabt und gut
abgesehen erst jetzt auch nicht zum
beispiel hat den booster eingesammelt
jetzt geht er auf sein tor das machen
nämlich die ganzen jetzt in dem spiel
stellen sie auf die torlinie also was
ist fertig macht apple noch nicht
deswegen finde ich es nicht cool scheiße
schritt aber es ist endlich ganz
effektiv
ok jetzt packe monster war okay
richtig hoch und jetzt läuft es perfekt
66 unrein name sehr schön halter dann
ist das problem man darf bei rocket
league endlich nicht stehenbleiben finde
ich zumindest man sollte immer in
bewegung bleiben bestehen bleibt dann
passiert so überhaupt keine
ballkontrolle mehr man hat überhaupt
keinen moment mehr bestimmt wenn man den
ball erwischt dann fliegt auch nirgendwo
hin
so war man umso leichter schießt die
weniger schwung monat gut wenn man fast
steht dann passiert wird überhaupt
nichts deswegen immer vollgas geben die
boost sammelt ist ein bisschen meine
taktik 42 jetzt nein nein nein junge
wichtig alter entweder draußen
weggelockt beherzten buchs code 9
sekunden noch hoch und runter durch
kommen drei treffer geht noch ein
treffer geht noch was ist fakt wir
müssten gewonnen okay sein als man sich
gefallen hat leute lassen daumen nach
oben da schreibt eure meinung zu rocken
kommentar bis dann